[音楽]
音に吐きがないというわけでこちらがあの
ちょっと最近笛ラムネでオーケストラを
やった時のフエラムネの余りですま今聞い
てもらったと思ですけどで音がなるんです
けども音に覇気がないんすよ音に覇気が
ないんで今日はこちらのね今日こちらに笛
ラムネがたくさんあります何個だろう笛
ラムが160個ぐらいあるんで今日は今日
はこちらのふえラムを160個ねこう
くっつけて縦笛を作りますうん1個だと
こういうなんかしょぼい音しかなないん
ですけど多分縦笛にすればもうねそれは
もう楽器ですよもうもう完全にもう
リコーダーとかそういうねあのあのタイの
楽器になると思うんで今日は作るよ
まこういう感じですねこうだこうこうこう
そうそうそうそれそれそれでテープで繋い
でいきますああいい
ねいいねあおいおいバカ野郎いしい1回
積もう全部積み
ますおいおいおい
おいこれさ
あ
[音楽]
お分かりいただけるだろうか多分ねこう
いう感じっすよこうだねこうやってテープ
で多分繋げてけばできますこうやって
テープで繋げてけば多分できますんでもう
ちょい頑張り
[音楽]
ますこれ行ける
わ
[音楽]
まあまあねまあまあままちょっと笛という
よりなんか違うけどねま大丈夫しょこん
だけ重なってれば多分もうこの輪っかが
すごい繋がってるんで多分壮大なね
びっくりするぐらいの綺麗な色がね今日は
兼ねでられると思うんでちょっとね早速
引いてみようと思い
[音楽]
[拍手]
ます
[音楽]
OG
あ